سوف أتحدث باللغة العربية أولاً
ثم سأحاول ترجمتها مثل
الجمل القصيرة باللغة الإنجليزية ، لذلك نحن جميعًا
في نفس الصفحة ، حسنًا ، آمل أن يكون هذا جيدًا
الآن بالطبع أتحدث عن
إنشاء المحتوى ولماذا الناس  متردد في
إنشاء المحتوى ولكن ربما في نهاية
الخطاب ستدرك أن هذه هي
الأسباب التي تجعل الناس مترددين في
إنشاء أي شيء
على ما يرام ،
لذا من أنا لأتحدث عن هذه المجالات
أنا ميسون رحلة ملكة جمال وقد تمكنت من
إقناع نصف  مليون متابع
لمتابعي خلال عام ونصف العام
[ضحك]
لأنك ترى
أنني دُعيت ذات مرة إلى
قمة حكومية ودعوا الكثير من منشئي المحتوى الذين
لاحظوا أي شيء غريب بعض الشيء في الصورة
أنا الأقصر ولكن هذا ليس
لا ينبغي أن يكون مفاجأة ، نعم
بالطبع قال أحدهم أنني الفتاة الوحيدة
آسف
لماذا تتردد الفتيات في إنشاء
المحتوى الذي طرحته
هذا السؤال على
قصتي ثم تلقيت الكثير
من الإجابات من الفتيات و  الرجال والأشخاص
الذين لا يريدون
حتى إنشاء محتوى ولكنهم
مترددون في إنشاء أي شيء
لذلك حاولت جمع كل هذه المخاوف
التي واجهتها في بداياتي ولكني
نسيت على طول الطريق وسأخبرك
الآن  وجهات النظر حول تلك المخاوف
ربما أول ما يتبادر إلى ذهنك
هو التعليقات السلبية وكيف يمكننا التعامل
مع التعليقات السلبية ، فكر في
تخيل أنك تلقيت تعليقًا سلبيًا
من شخص عشوائي على الإنترنت
أجنبي
مرحبًا به للجميع ،
هل ستأخذ نصيحة من هذا
شخص
هل ستأخذ نصيحة من
شخص عشوائي على الإنترنت يعتقد
أنك تبدو قبيحًا لسبب ما بالطبع بالطبع
لن تفعل ذلك بالطبع
وهذا السؤال كان له تأثير
السحر علي في كل مرة يعلق فيها شخص ما
شيء غير ذي صلة ربما في مظهري
ربما في الطريقة التي أتحدث بها
أتأثر ولكن بعد ذلك أسأل نفسي هل
سأستمع إلى نصيحة من هذا
الشخص وفجأة أصبح لا أحدًا
فجأة هذه النصيحة سمعت ذلك
من صانع المحتوى وهي مثل
الذهبي  لذلك كررت لكل شخص
يسألني عن التعليقات السلبية ، حسنًا ،
والشيء الآخر هو الشيء الآخر
الذي لا ينبغي أن يكون مفاجئًا وكذلك الأشخاص
الأجانب
[الموسيقى]
الذين تخشون سماعهم من
الأشخاص الذين سمعتهم بالفعل
حيث
في
رأسك قلق تمامًا مما
يحدث مع الأشخاص المبدعين ، فنحن
صعبون جدًا على أنفسنا ،
لذا أعني أن الأسوأ قد حدث بالفعل ،
لذا ربما جربهم
جيدًا
أو
الشيء الثاني الذي يخشى الناس حقًا من
وضع أنفسهم
فيه  الإنترنت من أجل خصوصيته
كما هو الحال في الأشخاص العرب ، فنحن نحمي
خصوصيتنا للغاية ، فنحن لا نحب أن تعرف
المصورين أو الأشخاص الذين يحبون معرفتنا على
المقاعد والأشياء وأنا أحصل عليها ولكن
الشيء الذي
يفكر في الخصوصية هو
جمهورك
مرآتك
كيف تكون هذه الصلة بالموضوع
بالطبع ستطاردك كارما بشكل
أفضل هو أجنبي
إذا وضعت فضائح ورأيت
أشخاصًا للمحتوى بالطبع
سيعود جمهورك ويطاردك ولكن
إذا طرحت أفكارك إذا  استفزاز
سعيك
لإبداع جمهورك ، سيكونون مبدعين معك
وسيشاركونك المزيد من الأفكار ، وهذا هو
السبب في أن جمهورك هو
زواجك ،
شكرًا لك
ومرة ​​أخرى هذا الشيء المتعلق بالخصوصية ،
يجب أن نتوخى الحذر جميعًا ،
لكن هذا قول مأثور  أن
أذهب دائمًا إذا كنت شديد الحذر ،
لا تمشي لأنهم دائمًا
احتمال أن تعمل بشكل صحيح
لأنه ولكن ليس الدورات التدريبية جيدة ،
ثم لدينا هذا الشيء وسمعت
الكثير من الناس يقولون ذلك في
البداية  المجتمع ،
لماذا تخشى أن تضع نفسك
هناك؟
لك هو
النجاح
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
شيء آخر غريب
يأتي لي دائمًا مثل عندما يقول الناس أن
المجتمع يجعلنا ومجتمعًا وأنا
مثل من هو المجتمع إذا فكرت
في ذلك ،
فأنت مجتمع أنت أنت  جزء كبير
منه لأنه بطريقة ما تختار
الأشخاص المناسبين لك ، فإنك تختار دوائرك في
كل مكان في المدارس التي تختار
دوائرك فيها حتى في
التجمعات العائلية التي تختار من تجلس معها
ولا تقول دائمًا حسنًا ، حسنًا
قل مرحباً للجميع ولكن بعد ذلك تذهب إلى
Matalan مع أبناء عمومتك
وتشعر بمزيد من الراحة ، لذا في
النهاية أنت مجتمع إذا كنت تفعل
شيئًا لست مقتنعًا به
بالطبع سيكون الناس غاضبين ولكنك
تفعل شيئًا  سوف تبتهج
الناس من فعل الناس سوف يهتفون لك
حسنًا ،
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
أجنبي
[موسيقى]
لهذا السبب لا أريد أن أضع نفسي
هناك ليس لدي خبرة ولهذا
السبب لا أريد أن أبدأ
أسير في طريقي ، ليس لدي خبرة ،
لذا لا أريد أن أبدأ في هذه المهارة
وإجابتي على هذا
لا تنتظر
للبدء حتى تحصل على
برج لاتيني ذو خبرة وتختبر المتعلم
[تصفيق]